drei gipfel in sieben tagen erst der eu
gipfel jetzt der g7 gipfel anschließend
dann der nato gipfel der kalender des
bundeskanzlers dürfte ordentlich gefüllt
sein umso schöner dass er sich auch
heute zeit genommen hat für das zdf
morgenmagazin und damit einen schönen
guten morgen olaf scholz und morgen herr
scholz es gibt etliche themen bei ihnen
auf der agenda ukraine waffen energie
ernährung sicherheit wohlstand
wirtschaft wir beginnen mit dem
klimawandel und da ist es so dass er die
reichen staaten vor allen dingen
hauptverursacher der erderwärmung sich
weiterhin sperren gegen große
finanzzusagen trotz des pariser
klimaabkommen cia mit eine neue idee so
eine art club klima club was soll dieser
freiwillige verbund denn wirklich
bringen zunächst mal haben wir ja auf
den weg gebracht das es mit vielen
ländern des globalen südens konkrete
vereinbarungen gibt über
energiezusammenarbeit just energy
partnership für die veränderung und das
ist glaube ich ein zeichen dafür dass
wir fortschritte ganz konkret erreichen
wollen der klima club handelt davon dass
man zusammenarbeiten soll zwischen den
staaten die bereits sind sehr schnell
bis zur mitte dieses jahrhunderts co2
neutral zu werden es gibt
unterschiedliche wege die die staaten
einschlagen wollen aber das ziel muss
immer das gleiche sein deutschland ist
da ja sehr ehrgeizig wir wollen es schon
2045 schaffen es soll ja auch eine
einheitliche co2
preisen geben und da sagen die usa und
kanada da machen wir eher nicht mit also
ist dieser klub gestorben bevor er
überhaupt ins leben gerufen wurde nein
ich habe ja eben schon gesagt es geht
darum mit unterschiedlichen wegen am
gleichen ziel anzukommen und wenn einige
länder sowie deutschland zum beispiel
mit co2 bepreisung arbeiten und andere
länder andere wege einschlagen muss das
ziel trotzdem das gleiche sei nämlich zu
der veränderung unserer wirtschaft zu
kommen sodass wir erfolgreiche industrie
und wirtschaftsnationen bleiben mit
guten gut bezahlten arbeitsplätzen aber
eben co2 neutral wirtschaften in noch
nicht einmal 25 jahren im deutschen fall
und deshalb ist das glaube ich wirklich
eine große herausforderung bei der man
sich unterhaken muss darum geht es auch
bei der gruppe d das haben wir ja
gesehen die bilder haben das gestern
schon mal eindrücklich gezeigt g und
entschlossenheit soll demonstriert
werden beim pariser klimaabkommen was ja
zum großteil nicht eingehalten wird da
würden sich diverse länder freuen wenn
das passieren würde zum beispiel
südafrika indonesien oder aber auch
indien länder die sie herr bundeskanzler
auf die seite ich sag's mal ein bisschen
salopp der demokraten ziehen wollen nun
waren es aber auch genau die drei länder
die sich zum beispiel bei der
uno-vollversammlung
enthalten haben als es darum ging den
angriffskrieg russland zu verurteilen
und auch bei den westlichen sanktionen
eher unverständnis zeigen bisher wie
wollen sie oder womit wollen sie die
eigentlich überzeugen mit geld zunächst
einmal darf man nicht in die falle
tappen die putin aufstellt zu behaupten
die welt sei geteilt und dem globalen
westen also die g7 und ihre freunde im
norden und alle anderen das stimmt ja
nicht demokratien gibt es in der ganzen
welt und sie haben sehr ähnliche
perspektiven deshalb ist es eine sehr
bewusste entscheidung gewesen dass sich
hier die von ihnen genannten länder
eingeladen habe indonesien indien
südafrika senegal und argentinien einige
davon haben bei der generalversammlung
der vereinten nationen mit gestimmt und
russland verurteilt kein land hat sich
auf die seite los russlands geschlagen
auch das muss man ja dazu sagen aber
deshalb ist es ja umso wichtiger dass
wir miteinander diskutieren und wir
müssen hier auch solidarität zeigen denn
der russische angriffskrieg hat ja
konsequenzen für die ganze welt viele
länder fürchten eine hungerkrise viele
länder fürchten massiv steigende
energiepreise wie wir sie ja auch spüren
wegen den neu entstehenden knappheiten
und dass sie möglicherweise nicht die
nötige energie für ihre länder besorgen
können und da muss man solidarisch
zusammenstehen diese solidarität wollen
wir auch zeigen und das ist dann auch
vielleicht ein ganz wichtiges argument
dafür dass wir in der künftigen welt
zusammenarbeiten
also sie wollen sie mit dem argument der
solidarität überzeugen da bin ich
gespannt ob ihnen das gelingen wird
jetzt haben sie gerade ried tschuldigung
wir müssen solidarität auch selber
zeigen darum geht es ja deshalb zb die
energie partnerschaften über die ich
gesprochen habe gerade mit mehreren
dieser länder aber auch indem zum
beispiel wenn es um die frage geht was
machen wir damit es keine hungerkrise in
der welt gibt dass wir dort zusammen
aber jetzt haben sie die hungerkrise
angesprochen dass es sie nicht gibt aber
sie gibt es und zwar ziemlich dramatisch
der und zwar lesen wir aus dem
auswärtigen abend 345 millionen menschen
seien laut der außenministerin annalena
baerbock akut von einer hungerkrise
betroffen das sind 200 millionen mehr
als noch vor zweieinhalb jahren gründe
gibt es dafür einige unter anderem jetzt
aber eben auch der durch putin
angezettelte krieg der verschärft das
ganze was werden sie tun ganz schnell
und ganz konkret wir haben schon
vorbereitet dass wir uns auch
verständigen eine
gemeinsame aktivität zustande zu bringen
der wäre auch mit finanzmitteln dafür
sorgen dass eben eine solche hungerkrise
vermieten wird und gleichzeitig bemühen
wir uns zusammen mit dem generalsekretär
der vereinten nationen mit dem wir heute
auch sprechen werden darum dass es
gelingt zum beispiel aus der ukraine
getreide zu exportieren da sind jetzt
gegenwärtig tag und nacht die
verhandlungen im gange und wir begleiten
das alle gemeinsam mit größter sorge und
der bereitschaft zu helfen ja hunger als
waffe energie als waffe der ukrainische
präsident der heute gegen 10 uhr
zugeschaltet werden soll zum g7-treffen
der wird um echte waffen bitten werden
sie wird deutschland das forcieren also
werden sie dieser bitte schnell
nachkommen deutschland liefert sehr
viele waffen das wird auch überall
anerkannt wie sie ja selber berichtet
haben eben und das ist ein gutes zeichen
dieses gipfels deutschland hat
weitreichende entscheidungen getroffen
der das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr das wir auf den weg gebracht
haben die höheren ausgaben für
verteidigung die massive unterstützung
der ukraine wird überall als ein
wichtiger beitrag deutschlands bewertet
und ist es im übrigen auch das ist gut
manchmal so zusammen zu kommen weil das
ja den blick etwas weitet und dann auch
klar macht dass tatsächlich gerade
deutschland eine zentrale rolle spielt
und sie auch weiter spielen wird aber
wird es weitere waffen geben wenn die
garage präsident sagt er das reicht
alles noch nicht ganz wir tun's die
ganze zeit und sie haben das ja auch
berichte wir haben jetzt entschieden
dass wir dazu beitragen dass es
panzerhaubitzen gibt die geliefert
werden die modernsten wir haben
ausgebildet eine zeitlang wurde ja
diskutiert warum bildet man darauf
überhaupt aus aber jetzt sind sie da und
können auch genutzt werden das gleiche
machen wir mit mehrfach raketenwerfern
wo jetzt die ausbildung beginnt die
haben wir übrigens geliefert zusammen
mit den usa und großbritannien auch ein
zeichen dafür dass es vielleicht doch
etwas praktischer in kooperation
stattfindet als mancher hierzulande
manchmal wendt und gleichzeitig ist es
so dass wir gesagt haben wir
konzentrieren uns auch darauf das zu tun
was sehr hilfreich ist in dem wir gerade
bei der verteidigung des luftraums
helfen mit den platt panzern die wir zur
verfügung stellen wo auch gerade die
ausbildung in deutschland stattfindet
oder zb mit der lieferung eines
hochmodernen systems das in der lage ist
eine stadt wie odessa oder kiew und
dessen lot großraum zu verteidigen also
wir sind ganz konkret dabei mit den
modernsten sachen die ganz konkret
helfen und hier auch wirklich nötig und
hilfreich sind traurigerweise scheint ja
eine politische lösung irgendwie nicht
gerade in greifbarer nähe zu sein die
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen hat sich gestern dafür
ausgesprochen den g20-gipfel im november
in indonesien nicht zu boykottieren
der gastgeber hat ja explizit auch
russland dazu eingeladen schließen sie
sich ursula von der leyen da an gipfel
nicht boykottieren auch wenn putin
kommen sollte ein sehr guter präsident
der g20 der indonesische präsident mit
dem wir heute auch sprechen werden hat
ja auch präsident selensky aus der
ukraine eingeladen deshalb weiß ich auch
gar nicht werden und alles da
tatsächlich erscheinen wird und zum
beispiel wie die konkrete
zusammensetzung sein wird aber eins ist
klar die g20 müssen auch weiter eine
rolle spielen nächstes jahr wird indien
präsident der g-20 seien und die
zusammenarbeit ist wichtig das ist das
was wir auch im blick haben müssen ganz
konkrete erscheinung dass sie
entschuldigen sie dass ich sie
unterbreche bundeskanzler kann ich davon
aber ableiten dass sie hinfahren egal ob
putin kommt oder nicht
wir werden am ende die entscheidung kurz
vor der abreise treffen müssen weil ja
die welt läuft die sich bis dennoch sehr
erheblich verändern können aber eines
ist ganz klar die g 20 spielen eine
große rolle und wir wollen mit denen eng
zusammenarbeiten darüber sind sich alle
staaten hier einig und deshalb gibt es
die gemeinsame überzeugung das hat frau
von der leyen ja auch ausgedrückt dass
wir die g20 nicht torpedieren wollen
herr bundeskanzler ist es sommer der
herbst scheint noch weit weg zu sein die
dicken pullis auf und heizung muss auch
noch keiner auf drehen sie wissen ich
will jetzt über das thema energie
sprechen bevor wir das machen schon zum
kurzen einspieler an
willkommen im internationalen klima club
der g7 der klima klub noch zukunftsmusik
ebenso wie das ziel der g7 gegen die
klimakrise setzen wir g7 auf ausstieg
aus fossilen energie aber auch das noch
zukunftsmusik denn die über neutralen
wirtschaft die rutscht wegen der
aktuellen diskussion um die abhängigkeit
von russischem gas und öl in weite ferne
die folgen deutschland muss sparen an
gas und öl damit die gasspeicher bis zur
heizperiode zu 90 prozent gefüllt sind
das erklärte ziel also der der massive
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien bleibt
wieder nur zukunftsmusik also muss das
deutsche wirtschaftsministerium umdenken
beim sparen hilft jetzt ein fossiler
brennstoff die kohle
braunkohle ist nicht die antwort für die
übergangsphase nun wohl doch ein buch
tabubruch wohl nicht nur für den grünen
deutschen wirtschaftsminister sondern
auch für die restlichen g7-staaten ein
dilemma
ja ein dilemma und das alles weil wir
den umstieg auf die fossile energie
nicht wirklich passiert haben und b und
sehr abhängig gemacht haben von russland
was energie anbelangt und das führt uns
diese angriffskrieg natürlich aktuell
noch mal schmerzlich vor augen herr
bundeskanzler besonders schmerzlich für
sie dürfte auch sein dass russland
dieses jahr ein drittel mehr
verdient hat als 20 21 wenn wir uns also
die sanktion anschauen das sechste paket
ist gerade verabschiedet worden ergeben
die wirklich sinn die aktion die
sanktionen geben wirklich sinn sie haben
dazu beigetragen dass die russische
wirtschaft erheblich geschwächt worden
ist und sie wird es auch weiter denn ein
land das vom technologischen fortschritt
mehr oder weniger abgeschnitten ist wird
in kurzer zeit erheblich wirtschaftlich
zurückfallen das weiß und russland auch
jeder und deshalb ist es schon so dass
diese sanktion ihre wirkung entfalten
trotzdem gibt es natürlich
herausforderung die wir zu bewältigen
haben wir haben immer gesagt die
sanktionen sollen vor allem den
russischen präsidenten die russische
regierung und russland treffen damit sie
den angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
beenden aber gleichzeitig werden sie
auch konsequenzen bei uns haben und wir
haben sehr früh angefangen uns darauf
vorzubereiten schon im dezember kaum
dass die neue regierung etabliert war
haben wir angefangen zu sprechen was
machen wir eigentlich wenn es
schwierigkeiten bei den
energielieferungen gibt und waren
deshalb sehr gut vorbereitet als der
krieg begann ich konnte wenige tage
später im deutschen bundestag sagen wir
werden jetzt alles dafür tun dass wir in
größter geschwindigkeit terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten bauen um flüssiggas
importieren zu können das ist im gange
die gesetze dazu sind alle beschlossen
so dass wir mit größter geschwindigkeit
das tun wir haben auch dafür sorge
getragen dass die speicher gefüllt
werden indem wir entsprechende gesetze
auf den weg gebracht haben und wir haben
auch die mutige und notwendige
entscheidung getroffen zu sagen jetzt
brauchen wir vorübergehend
stromproduktion mit kohlekraftwerken
damit wir das in diesem sommer sparen
können wenn putin den gashahn zudreht
haben wir natürlich trotzdem probleme
aber soweit ist es noch nicht noch eine
schnelle frage gold embargo das will der
us-präsident schließen sie sich da an
wir diskutieren diese frage aber das
wird auch im kreis der europäischen
union diskutiert werden müssen deshalb
ist es keine sache wo abschließend die
g7 darüber entscheiden aber dass wir
unsere sanktionen immer weiter
präzisieren das ist schon etwas worauf
sich alle verlassen können die das
unterstützen und damit auch die
russische regierung rechnen muss einsatz
will ich noch sagen weil mir das wichtig
ist damit das nicht stehen bleibt der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien hat
jetzt in deutschland richtig fahrt
aufgenommen hier treffen dieses jahr
sehr viele entscheidungen ändern sehr
viele gesetze damit das tempo dass sie
zu recht für die letzten jahre vermissen
jetzt auch tatsächlich gelingt und wir
haben uns vorgenommen dass wir die
stromproduktion auf erneuerbare energien
umstellen dass wir unsere
stromproduktion ausweiten und dass wir
es schaffen unser industrielles modell
mehr auf elektrizität und wasserstoff zu
konzentrieren was die voraussetzung für
co2 neutralität ist wir sind also bei
der arbeit sagt der deutsche
bundeskanzler olaf scholz vielen dank
für ihre zeit und wenn sie die arbeit
schon angesprochen haben die geht jetzt
weiter bis morgen noch der g7 gipfel und
dann geht es direkt weiter zum
nato-gipfel danke tschüss